even on the day on the way to the red
carpet or in the limo just to wind her
up I said oh I'm going to start off with
a funny little one-liner just an
old-fashioned Joker she went oh what I
said them what did the death dumb and
blind orphan get for Christmas and Jane
went I don't know I said cancer
properties
said that Fame is the perfume of heroic
Deeds Fame is the perfume of heroic
Deeds well it probably was back then
there was no heat magazine the Big
Brother you actually had to do something
famous you were a great scholar or a
leader of men and all the way through
history that was the case 500 years ago
the most famous man on the planet was
Leonardo Da Vinci because of all the
great things he did he was a painter he
was an inventor
oh oh go on mate sorry
I can't do one-on-one it's a big place
in a much smaller room I still ignore
you can't shush
[Applause]
I fell back in love with stand up on my
last tour Humanity I played Arenas
around the world Netflix bought it for a
record amount it was the most watched
special of the year I thought everyone
loves me now everyone loves me now then
I got this tweet
real tweet I
call yourself a comedian
he knows I do
literally says the word in my Twitter
bio
call yourself a comedian you're about as
funny as now I thought he was going to
go for the jugular and say Miranda oh
come on
come on guys don't
[Applause]
I'm joking right
call yourself a comedian you're about as
funny as a fart at a baby's funeral
he was trying to hurt my feelings
but his big mistake was choosing someone
that would be [__] hilarious
as if that would a far a baby's funeral
big echoey church everyone just silently
saw being like that
tiny little coffin tiny little coffin
and someone farts
you'd laugh even if it was your baby you
know no
if you're at the funeral it's been dead
a week do you know what I mean it's
you're probably up for a giggle um
particularly if you're the father if
you're the mother you probably still
find The Artsy in the funny side of
things
but I'm a considered comedian I like my
jokes to be accurate and my targets to
be fair so I was engaging these people I
was saying
why is it transphobic and they were
saying it's about trans person so that's
ridiculous that's like saying a joke
about Bill Cosby's automatically racist
it depends on the joke but I was talking
to them I'm willing to learn and I found
out my crime was that I dead named her
now I'd never heard that term you know
before a day after the Golden Globes and
that was saying her old name and even
acknowledging that she used to be a man
but she did I
saw him on the Olympic Games it was a
it was the Catholic it was in everything
it was all over the place of sharper and
pole vault is they won a medal he was
famous he was on telly all the time but
you know a big famous man with a huge I
don't know but I mean I'm guessing
probably he's a big but I've learned my
lesson now I'd never dead name her now
and I know it's wrong I'd never dead
name her now but like years ago
um when you know she was a a man
um that was years ago I'm saying right
and she went to the doctor right and
knocked on the door and the doctor went
come in this is years ago I I was saying
I've never dead name her now but this is
like this is like a flashback before
anyone do not have so look come in and
they were they went hello Bruce Jenner
because that that was his name Ben the
doctor you know this was years ago and
the doctor went I want to Bruce Jenny a
big how you doing boy you [__]
what are you doing man
yeah
who's your boy you're right right and
Bruce Jenner because that was his name
this is years ago right so
Bruce Jenner went yeah yeah not too bad
doctor yeah it's too bad right
what can I do for you Bruce yeah [__] uh
how you doing boy
and Bruce Jenner went because that was
his name Bruce Jenner went
look at that
[Applause]
and then well come on Bruce Jenner you
know the rules it used his whole name
every time for some reason I don't know
why
come on Bruce Jenner you [__] you know
the rules you you can't bring your big
old pole vault in Poland here mate you
know and Bruce Jenner went no that's not
my pole Vine but that's my enormous
penis
and I'm all right yeah seeing this is
your penis you can bring it in here but
you shouldn't let your shot puts outside
and Bruce Jenner went that that was his
name for
58 years I think
they're my enormous testicles
I'll get my testosterone or my spark and
[__] that's right and the doctor went oh
yeah that makes perfect I am medical man
and that you're you're a big bloke off
you [__] how you doing boy you're a
big
you you big and you would have a big old
[__] and balls they're beautiful that
bit familiar and I know but you must be
very proud of them Bruce
oh this is going to surprise you doctor
I want to get rid of them
why why ah they get in the way get in
the way of what [__] driving for one
thing
foreign
school with this guy right he was a Dev
kid um no he was I talk about my other
two stand-up shows his name was David
Beasley he's the one that said if you
get captured by cannibals when they're
cooking you in the pot they show you
pornographic pictures so you get an
erection and there's more meat to go
around
but it will be a very funny story as
well um there was a scandal in this sort
of neighborhood a guy a few doors away
from him that was older than him an
older boy had got done for lewd Behavior
he was cottagent he was a a gay guy in
there he'd gone down to this public
toilet in Cemetery Junction which is an
area of reading
and he'd gone into this um cubicle got
the hole there and he was waiting people
come in and out he waited for ages and
eventually came up someone came and
wrestling
[__] comes through oh
he grabbed it
can't get away then
I guess I've never tried it
he sucked him off
what do you think he was gonna do
play London's burning because
this dental floss is Big it causes
so he sucked him off
and when they both went outside it was
his dad
oh
all the Colgate in the world would never
get rid of that will it
oh
I don't know if you're affected by the
volcanic ash cloud but I had friends
that were stuck all over the world and
they missed weddings and funerals and
they had to put themselves up in a hotel
for extra days other than budgeted for
and they couldn't get their money back
because the airlines were saying no we
can't pay you because the insurance
companies won't pay us because they're
saying it's an act of God
what isn't an act of God
look if you believe in God that's sort
of a definition of him isn't it that he
does everything isn't that right
everything is an act of him is
all-powerful he's everywhere at what he
invented there was nothing before him he
invented time everything he's across it
all okay he doesn't miss a trick and
he's not absent-minded a volcano going
off isn't like him going [__] I'll lift
the oven on you know it's
I know where these insurance companies
that can decide what is and isn't Act of
God how do they know okay have they got
a hotline to God they've called him up
do they ring ring ring ring yellow
uh could I speak to God please speaking
oh I didn't think you'd answer the phone
yourself
what'd you want
oh um that volcanic ash cloud uh was
that you yeah
yes that was an act of me all right so I
shouldn't pay out no don't [__] pay
him a penny son no
brilliant brilliant well I've got you
here um did you make a tree fall on
Steve Baxter's car
there's a lot of Steve Baxters
um Steve Baxter two Acacia Road Hounslow
it happened at 2 15 on the 3rd of June
this year 215 30 no
that wasn't me
I was in Africa that day giving aids to
babies
he does everything he does everything
now you're not to know this but I am
usually in my pajamas by 6PM I've come
home from work the Telly goes on the
pajamas go on even if there's company
it's you know I mean my house my rules
pajamas on and if we got you know
relatives around Jane says oh I'm not
the ones with the holes in that's all
she asks so I mean you don't need your
mother-in-law when you bend over it's
like the last chicken in the window
going he's got a tumor you know I mean
it's just
but you don't want to throw them away
your pajamas they get nicer with age
they get soft don't they and they fit
you just right no one's going to see him
he just I actually invented a game with
an old pair of pajamas with a hole in
them no you know when it gets sort of
really thin in the gasket then suddenly
a little hole appears you get like a a
quarter of an inch sort of hole and when
blokes are watching telly we sort of we
sort of doodle do you know what I mean I
don't know why with it's sort of like a
comfort thing I think it's
anthropological I think chimps Do It
um not on me on them
no good to me they haven't got opposable
thumbs or anything so I've never tried
to get a chimp to wank me off so let's
nip that one
and I discovered right that if I pulled
out miscellaneous bits of skin right no
it could be a bit of scrotal sack
could be a hint of foreskin you only put
it out half an inch you've got a guess
whip that's the it's called awful Jim
Jam no
and you just pull it out just half an
inch right and you turn to your
girlfriend and you go awful Jim Jam [__]
or ball
[Applause]
it might be genius
um
there's no reincarnation no Ghosts no
Heaven I believe people can't go over
that people quiz me onto it when they
find out I'm an atheist they go well you
don't believe in God at all go no do you
pray I go no
why don't you pray just in case there's
a God and I say why do you put Garlic
over your door just in case there's a
Dracula right and I've got no problem
with praying you know I know loads of
nice Christians and Muslims and Jews and
if one of my family is very ill they all
say oh I pray for them and I always say
oh thanks very much because it's a nice
gesture if they said oh we also canceled
the chemotherapy I go don't do that
don't do that
try fill your boots son but let's
let's do the praying and the
chemotherapy shall we because that's the
same result as just the chemotherapy so
let's let's definitely keep that one
shall we
I got in trouble talking about praying
on Twitter once remember a few years ago
that terrible disaster in Oklahoma the
the hurricane people lost their lives
and their livelihood and I donated to
the Red Cross and I tweeted about it
with a link saying you can donate here
too trying to help them with their drive
and one of those sort of frivolous
entertainment magazines from America
their account tweeted this thing it
really annoyed me they tweeted Beyonce
and Rihanna send prayers to Oklahoma and
I tweeted back going oh I feel like a
[__] only sent money
[Applause]
someone tweeted me once would you come
to the bedside of a Dying child and tell
them there's no Heaven I tweeted back is
it a paid gig
[Laughter]
I prefer dogs obviously dogs are better
people than people aren't they they are
they're amazing dogs they're our best
friends they guard us they guide us
there's medical detection dogs that can
smell if you've got like AIDS
um I I'm not a doctor but their noses
are like a thousand times more sensitive
than us so they sort of go poor you're
well HIV [__] you know
and you know you you smell Aids on
someone yeah yeah then why didn't you
smell it on the bloke I bought home last
night then you [__] idiot
it's three billion years by themselves
Evolution and all that and then we got
involved and we did a bit of selective
breeding you know getting them out we
wanted them to do jobs for us you know a
bit more of that Bit Stronger Faster
whatever and they're great at the jobs
they're bred to do and they love the job
they're bred to do because they're
genetically hardwired to love that
behavior anyway although the Rhodesian
Ridgeback was bred to hunt lions and I
can't help but think that was a little
bit of a shock to it when it found out
um so we've done all the breeze and all
the different pedigrees all thousands of
all the miles around a big passing out
parade there's a bloke in a square with
a white coat and a clipboard and he goes
right dogs and they'll go what what who
wants to know what jobs they've got we
all do we all do okay Labradors yeah
do you like carefully bringing back dead
ducks
yeah
that's your job amazing that is amazing
that is my favorite job that is my
favorite job
Jack Russells yeah do you like shooting
down rabbit holes after yeah
that's your job [__] Our Best Day
Ever best day ever
miniature poodles yeah do you like being
carried around by elderly homosexuals
yeah that's the job
Ridgebacks yo
thank you
you're hunting Lions what
you aren't in lions
[__] off
yeah you are no no we're not Lions we
get [__] mashed why can't the
Rottweilers hunt lions
they're shaking babies
shake that baby if you want good boy
cheers
[Music]
coming down
to be quite political growing up that 15
16 year old becoming aware and wow you
did it to annoy your parents obviously
but
um I think we're inundated with politics
from an early age I think everything is
charged with politics and morality and
the way to live
um it's in everything fables nursery
rhymes little sayings
um I remember I must be as young as six
when we used to have an assembly at
school and Infant School we'd all come
in every Monday and sit down on the
floor cross-legged and our deputy
admasters and tell us a story and it
always had a moral that we were meant to
think about and this would make us into
leaders of Men character building and he
used to take ages over it and he loved
it it was his best day you know and uh I
remember he told us
about the two mice
the lazy Mouse
and the industrious Mouse
and it was summer and these two little
mice were out in the woods the sun was
out
streams were babbling there was flowers
there were berries there were nuts there
was ah and lazy Mouse he'd just be
running around in the sun having a bite
from a berry throwing the rest away
there was loads it was never going to
run out
industrious Mouse he'd have a very shore
but he'd eat it all and he'd put one
away for a colder season he knew
lazy Mouse he would he'd be [__]
running about somebody then he
eventually I throw in the rest away
industrious and I went oh be careful
lazy Mouse cause come when I'll [__] off
your Square
[Applause]
the fall comes same sort of pattern the
last of barriers he's chewing there and
throwing the rest away he's just like
chilling out he's kicking through the
leaves you can't see him he's if you saw
the leaves moving yeah
he'd be under the leaves basically you
go what's that it's lazy Mouse
underneath the lip if you could go under
there like the Discovery Channel
you'd see lazy Mouse going [__] it
[Laughter]
industrious Mouse
putting freeze drying loads of berries
he'd be chopping wood and that he he
made an ax to chop the word here
out of a little twig
and this sliver of Flint
and she tied on with her horse hair
thus enabling him to chop and stockpile
fuel
so
winter comes
different pattern
the ground's hard there's nothing
there's no fruit There's No Berries
there's no nuts there's nothing at all
on those trees
and he's can't find anything that he's
starving
and he's freezing and he's looting his
body waiting
of course industrious Mouse now he's in
his Cottage
that he built
somehow
roaring log fire
sitting there rocking
on a pebble
knock at the door who's that obviously
so he goes over the door
he opens the door
it's lazy Mouse and he goes
what do you want
I'm cold
and I'm hungry
I can't find any food and I think I'm
gonna die he goes well I did warn you
didn't I
he goes yeah he goes never mind come in
here and share with me
where's the moral there
[__] around do what you want and then
scrounge off a doogle that's a terrible
moral for children isn't it
before
he told us the one about the boy who
cried wolf have you heard that
oh well I'm gonna tell you again
boy
in the Bible I don't know it's
I haven't got a specific year am I right
boy looking after the the sheep for the
villagers that's his job look after
those sheep boy you know yeah but he
gets a bit bored probably gets a bit
sleepy if he's counting him right and he
thinks oh I'll have a laugh here
because
wolf wolf and the villagers come up and
they go where's the wolf he goes there's
no wolf I go
so next day he gets bored again
that worked the tree it's got very
little imagination he goes I'll do that
again okay
so he goes
wolf
where's the wolf there's no wolf
so next day
sitting there there really is a wolf and
the wolf comes up and he goes wolf wolf
wolf but the villagers don't come and
the wolf eats all the Sheep
and we were told the moral of that is
never tell a lie
no it isn't
the moral of that is never tell the same
lie twice
[Applause]
a terrible moral for children
nursery rhymes Jack and Jill went up the
hill to fetch a pile of water
Jack fell down and broke his crown which
I later learned meant his cranium
I've always that fell off
and Jill came tumbling after and that's
a true Fable of 16th century lovers used
to go up to the the well behind the
prying eyes of the villagers and their
spouses and have it away and what's the
moral there though
don't [__] around with [__] or you get
your head caved in
how is that applicable to five-year-olds
[Applause]
I have never worked out the moral to
Humpty Dumpty
[Laughter]
sat on a wall
Humpty Dumpty had a great fall all the
king's horses and all the king's men
couldn't put Humpty together again
all I can think is
don't sit on a wall if you're an egg
but again how is that applicable to a
five-year-old human I mean
you tell that to a group of five oh so
don't sit on a water if you know what do
you mean if I'm an egg I'm not an egg
um doesn't make sense if I win none of
us are eggs if there was an egg there it
wouldn't make sense could you go to the
egg don't sit on a water go I'm an egg I
can't hear you I've got nothing I know
ears no eyes I don't know what the [__]
what don't I can't [__] hear I don't
I don't
I've got nothing this is I'm in
nothingness I can't [__] climb walls
for a start so
don't send horses to perform medical
procedures
they couldn't put him together again
[Laughter]
they've got no dexterity whatsoever
to save their life that they've got no
thumbs they're both opposable thumbs
don't send send a horse a Delica an egg
we've got a cracked egg so we send a
horse definitely not
have you got a doctor or someone who
works for Faberge don't
we've we've we've got like a half a ton
creature with no fingers no
don't send that
got a full-legged thing with like no no
no chance that they can't they put could
put on they couldn't scrub up they can't
[Applause]
magic those are there Delica egg horse
comes over
[__]
it couldn't they wouldn't even think of
[__] that's it
they wouldn't even see it they go over
there what the [__] that's it
wouldn't even you couldn't explain it
to it
don't send it's ridic if I had to design
the perfect egg crushing device it would
be a hoof
[Applause]
crack tagger I needed crushing
completely hoof
doesn't matter whether the king's horses
or not don't
certainly don't send all of them
that's gonna be chaos
if there was one horse with a little bit
announced he had to try he did like one
year before he got kicked out of Harvard
he could have I'd know the rudimentaries
all the [__] it off for [__] sake
all over it
[__] it's definitely [__] now
one of the first big Charities I got
involved with was the Terence Higgins
trust the big big AIDS charity and it
was it was mid to late 80s and people
were like what's this new thing called
AIDS what is oh it's gone from strength
to strength now we're doing
doing brilliantly it's gone global
so got its own day and everything first
of December World AIDS day I don't think
it'll ever pick up like Christmas we
don't do ending in our house there's no
no decorations but I discovered
something you're still learning it the
first HIV virus was a combination of two
separate viruses that combined in rhesus
monkeys and it made this rudimentary
form of veins and it was fatal to them
but this was passed a chimpanzee
sometimes chimpser get a blood blast and
eat a rhesus monkey and it evolved and
mutated in chimps and because we're 98.6
genetically identical to a chimpanzee it
was able to be passed to humans and the
first human contracted AIDS when he was
chopping up um chimp meat and cut his
finger although that's the excuse either
given
if you go oh I feel terrible doc doctor
goes I'm not surprised is it me
worse than Emmy you wish you had me you
should you should be laughing about he's
got terrible news no um
a terrible doctor you're the first human
to contract ains
is that bad it can't be
still laughing
how would I got that
two ways
one you were [__] a gym up the ass
me
no way
how else how else could how could I have
got it oh I don't know you could have
been chopping a chimp up cut your finger
that one
choppy chimpy finger one I bet he went
straight onto the jungle and found that
chip and went you gave me AIDS hello
I gave you a [__]
[Music]
shush no I got AIDS from you well where
did I get AIDS from eating monkeys well
I don't eat monkeys
I was eating them
foreign
Psychiatry Neuroscience it's still in
its infancy and we still know so little
about the brain than 150 years ago we
knew nothing it was just it was all
guesswork right and uh like everything
was just mental if you weren't a white
sort of heterosexual married Christian
man right if you deviated to Father
mental they just went mental like
homosexuality mental mental illness
you're putting an asylum for life or
Worse tortured women who felt prevent
out of wedlock mental Asylum for life
right and now we understand things more
we're more tolerant we're
I think it's going too far the other way
you know because now nothing's mental
you can't find somebody that someone's
nothing is considered mental everything
is a syndrome or an addiction or a
preference right I could have my legs
removed I have wheels put on identify as
a pram right
and if you sound mental you're a bigger
right now
that's a bit hack that joke now isn't it
oh it identify as a thing then right
it's a bit old-fashioned right but I'm
gonna leave it in to annoy people right
because that's the bit that'll offend
people same as Humanity I talk about
AIDS famine cancer the Holocaust rape
pedophilia but no the one thing you
mustn't joke about is identity products
the one thing you should never joke
about is the trans issue right they just
want to be treated equally I agree
that's why I include them
you know
but they know I'm joking about all the
other stuff but they go no no I must you
must be no he must mean that right like
like a joke is a window to the
comedian's true Soul it's just that's
just not the case uh I'll take on any
view to make the joke funniest I pretend
to be right wing I'll pretend to be left
wing I pretend to be clever I pretend to
be stupid whatever makes the joke
funnier without prejudice okay full
disclosure in real life of course I
support trans rights I support all human
rights and trans rights are human rights
you know live your best life use your
preferred pronouns be the gender that
you feel that you are but Meet Me
Halfway ladies lose the [__] that's all
I'm saying
that's cool
[Music]
when I am first moved in with my
girlfriend 20 odd years ago I first flat
together
it was a horrible place it was in King's
cross and it was horrible area Kings
Cross the city road seedy block horrible
little thing it was a rip-off but it's
all we could afford it was one room just
one room but it had like a little
kitchenette area
so what we decided to do we moved the
single bed sort of into there so we have
a lounge it was like a one bedroom so at
night we're in a space this big
the bed literally just fit in I had to
scrape it down the wall to get it in and
it came over the doorway a bit and in
bed I could open the fridge
the fridge was there the cooker was
there and the sink was there okay no
toilet the toilet was a shared toilet
with all the other flats in the blog and
it was two floors down
so what wins in the middle of the night
when I need a Wii
you know what I mean putting on trousers
and going outside or just pop into the
sink
that one and I remember 20 odd years ago
Jane in a sleepy State saying oh at
least take the dishes out first
I used to get old in the bottom plate
and lift them all up and weave straight
down the plug hole have you seen all the
Ghost Hunter shows years and years
Celebrity Ghost Hunter well all around
the world thousands and thousands of
hours of footage that they've never seen
a [__] ghost it's all like oh what
was that was it that I was just a no no
what did you hear that was it just that
was it you oh no
Wildlife programs are like that Amazon
watching David Attenborough all these
years and everybody goes here
I'm Kilimanjaro we see the oldest and by
the banks of the Limpopo The elusive
Powers
you can stop watching the
the pedo Hunter shows on the other hand
there's usually a couple in the crew
just in case
it's a BBC production
oh shut up